good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight one thing we have
learned after many years in the news
business is that every once in a while
you've got to eat some Crow and admit
that despite your best intentions you
were completely wrong about something
tonight is one of those times for nearly
four years now we've been under the
impression an impression we regularly
communicated to you our viewers that
actor Jesse smallett was the greatest BS
artist since Bill Clinton that he was a
transparent rakes race hoaxer who fooled
the dummies in the National media but
could not fool us that's what we thought
we thought Jesse smallett was a liar you
remember his story it did seem unlikely
late one night in Sub-Zero temperatures
in a snowstorm Jesse smallett decided to
venture out for a sandwich in downtown
Chicago when he was as people are
accosted by two physically enormous
Trump supporters from Africa who somehow
recognized him despite his ski hat from
his part in a little-known musical drama
series called Empire
because campy musical dramas are
apparently huge with muscle head Trump
voters from Nigeria so they knew him
instantly right away these two crazed
African right-wing Maniacs also
correctly guessed that Jesse smallett
had voted for Hillary Clinton and they
hated that and so As Trump voters so
often do they begin pummeling him about
the face and screaming this is Mega
country because that's one of the things
people typically say about downtown
Chicago it's maggot country then because
they were still angry they're always
angry these Nigerian racists poured
bleach on Jesse smallett threw a noose
around his neck and then ran off into
the night howling with demented Glee
you're so Jesse smallett described it
and I see
the attacker
masked and
he said this Maga country punches me
right in the face I was just jumped and
I then I looked down and I see that
there's a rope around my neck
yeah
we're gonna be honest with you we had
some questions about that story it just
didn't sound right to us something was
off
crazed Nigerian Trump voters assaulting
liberals in downtown Chicago how common
is this Chicago has 50 aldermen and not
a single one of them is a republican
Chicago has not had a Republican mayor
in 80 years Donald Trump got 12 percent
of the vote in Chicago it didn't really
seem like Maga country
but boy were we wrong not only is
Chicago a right-wing Donald Trump
stronghold last night the Q Anon Army
came for Lori Lightfoot Lightfoot of
course is the mayor of Chicago and a
consummate neoliberal she's the one who
prevented Chicago cops from chasing
criminals on foot because chasing
criminals is racist she's the mayor who
plunged Chicago even further further
into debt for a good cause to pay for
the Department of climate and
environmental equity
and in fact lightfoot's commitment
Equity was so profound that she banned
white reporters from talking to her she
took down not one but two statues of
Christopher Columbus who was a racist
so you would think if anybody would be
safe in Chicago which is roughly a
hundred percent Democratic party voters
it would be Lori Lightfoot oh but no
according to Lori Lightfoot The Extreme
Maga Republicans the ones who tried to
bleach jussie Smollett activated their
sleeper cells around the city and they
showed up at the polls on Moss which
means lots of them at once
and the effect was to make Lori
Lightfoot the first Chicago mayor in 40
years to lose re-election as Lightfoot
put it last night at her non-victory
party these Mega Republicans hated her
not because of what she did but because
of who she is ask directly whether her
defeat in the Democratic primary had
been unfair Lightfoot answered this way
quote I'm a black woman in America of
course
now one of the many tragedies here and
there are so many layers of tragedy is
that Lori Lightfoot insightful as she's
always been saw this racist Insurgency
coming for years here she was in 2021.
mayor in recent months there have been
questions raised about your your
temperament and your reaction to
criticism uh Tribune editorial use the
term irascible uh how much of this do
you think might have to do with the fact
that you're a woman and particular
specifically a black woman
about 99 of it
yeah because the thing is there are no
women in Chicago it's an entirely male
and right-wing City
and so all opposition to Lori Lightfoot
derived from her race and gender
it's not that people were angry about
violent crime in Chicago that never
crossed your mind no here instead is her
explanation from last night's concession
speech obviously we didn't win the
election today but I stand here with my
head held high and a Heart full of
gratitude I'm grateful that we work
together to remove a record number of
guns off our streets reduce homicides
and started making real progress on
public safety
obviously you didn't win that's true you
got spanked like the bad little mayor
you were
but according to the Chicago Police
Department we're all so happy she was
mayor because she made the city a lot
better here's what the police said in a
statement quote over the past three
years robberies burglaries and thefts
hit record lows in Chicago
categories so decreases not seen for the
last 50 years
oh it's a lot safer than it's ever been
in 50 years is that true well let's
check the same Police Department's own
statistics and here they are from 2019
to 2023 in Chicago robberies went up not
down actually up 27 percent theft nearly
40 percent murder kind of a significant
category 59 how about motor vehicle
theft is that up or down oh it's up
270 percent
so if you'd average all that out that
means all crime is up 33 percent there
were 300 more murders by gunshot in 2021
than there were in 2019 there were 2 000
more shooting victims there were 30
percent more overall shootings
so that's not a safer City actually
that's a much more dangerous city that
people are fleeing for their very lives
what's interesting is that the people in
charge of making the police safer are
still working to make it much more
dangerous
the top prosecutor in the city Lori
lightfoot's Allied Kim Fox is rejecting
thousands of felony cases every year
just not Prosecuting crimes in 2022 for
example Chicago prosecutors had a total
of 20 000 felony cases come in the door
and out of those they rejected right out
of hand two thousand they pursued out of
20 000 cases just 1900 to indictment not
to confectioners to indictment charging
people
and those numbers are not an anomaly
they're similar for every other year of
Lori lightfoot's historically disastrous
tenure as mayor and what's happening
what people are fleeing Chicago as noted
because they don't want to get killed
and you can see that in the home prices
where are home prices highest in America
of the 12 highest priced home markets in
America Niner in Florida
because people are fleeing there the
opposite is Drew of Chicago the medium
home price is less than the median home
price in the country as a whole in
fashionable Chicago the median home
price in Chicago is 270 thousand dollars
so who did this well it was a group
effort but Lori Lightfoot was the mayor
but it's not her fault you know whose
fault it is businesses and residents
pedestrians they made themselves easy
targets watch I'm disappointed that
they're not doing more to take safety uh
and make it a priority for example we
still have retailers that won't
Institute plans like having security
officers in their stores making sure
that they've got cameras that are
actually operational
locking up their merchandise at night
chaining high-end bags these purses seem
to be something that is attracting a lot
of attention on these organized retail
theft units
wait what did she just blame the stores
for getting robbed how is that different
from saying well you're wearing a halter
top of course you got raped I mean it's
not different actually it's blaming the
victim it's disgusting what was last
time you saw a mayor of a city blame
Crime Victims for being victimized well
you just saw Lori Lightfoot do it
so crime is no longer punished by and
large in Chicago unless you disrespect
Lori lightfoot's Authority
and in that case you went straight to
jail watch
Lieutenant Brown took
trick take
full attention
this is how it's going to be we will
shut you down we will cite you and if we
need to we will arrest you and we will
take you to jail period
we will take you to jail we'll arrest
you and take you to jail not if you
shoot somebody if you break Lori
lightfoot's covet law
but of course covid law didn't apply to
her because why would dictators follow
their own edicts and so Lori Lightfoot
immediately broke the state's
stay-at-home order to get a haircut and
when she was busted getting her hair cut
not a very good haircut we'll have to
say she blamed of course everybody else
I'm the public face of this city I'm on
National media and I'm out in the public
eye and you know I'm I'm a person who I
take my personal hygiene very seriously
as I said I felt like I needed to have a
haircut I'm not able to do that myself
and so I got a haircut
so now Lori Lightfoot is gone
who comes next we have no idea we don't
live in Chicago we're not even going to
speculate on the state of local politics
in that City all we know is the most
flamboyantly horrible mayor in the
country was punished the system worked
and if it worked in Chicago maybe it
could work in New Orleans where Latoya
Cantrell is quickly destroying one of
those Charming cities in the world
but part of us if we're being honest
will miss Lori Lightfoot despite all the
human suffering she caused there's part
of us that kind of enjoyed it by
embodying every one of her party's
excesses over the past four years Lori
Lightfoot inadvertently helped to expose
them here you had a complete buffoon
someone who ran around bragging about
having a large penis with we're just
telling you what she said somehow
running one of the greatest cities in
the world
at times it didn't seem like even Lori
Lightfoot could believe she was mayor
clearly didn't really care for the job
here she is
[Music]
yeah all we need is us
happy Halloween everyone happy Halloween
throwing the Destroyers
[Music]
and I'm happy to report
I'm calling out the census cowboy
[Music]
just save the tape save the tape that's
always our counsel from May of 2020 till
now March 1st of 2023 American
politicians the entire class have gone
completely insane and a lot of it is
caught on video in future Generations
won't believe it when you tell them so
save the tape
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight